got quite a bit to show you that you
haven't seen before want the inside
scoop on harry potter and the half blood
prince
we've got you covered we all know and
love the harry potter series
with the half blood prince being one of
the classics but did you know about all
the magic and effort put into the
behind-the-scenes production that made
the movie come to life
one's ready broomstick's ready and away
we go
right from the get-go it seems like
harry potter and the half-blood prince
is
chock-full of special and practical
effects which make the film stand out
as the production team has led on this
harry potter film has about the same
amount of special effects as any of the
other films
these special effects stand apart from
the other films though and how they are
integrated into the scenes
the use of cgi and other effects is much
more blended into the real world acting
and settings that the film uses
with explosive devices in all the
various different parts of the bathroom
so as soon as you
just spell someone load up the behind
the scenes of these effects makes the
film all the more interesting to watch
in its final form
it's crazy to think about all the
possibilities that arise when a simple
green screen is involved
green screens were used throughout this
film to create the cgi effects that blow
viewers away
for the quidditch scenes in the film the
use of blue screens was truly imperative
to creating the right shots
in reality actors were simply seated on
bicycle seats and fitted with a harness
on something that resembled a broomstick
while placed in front of a blue screen
all the magic of the quidditch game and
the intense background and action
were mostly added in digitally it's
quite tricky for me
because it's nothing to react to one
really interesting and unique iteration
of the green screen
is in the magical bookshelf scene of the
half-blood prince in this behind the
scenes look we can see green hands
extending from the bookshelves that
hermione is standing in front of
in the end these hands would be
digitally erased leaving behind the
effect of books magically being placed
back in their rightful spots within the
library
in the burrow burn scene we can see a
green well blue
screen extending in the background of
the shot this blue screen was used to
enhance the locational setting where the
scene was actually taking place
in the borough burn scene where in the
weasley family home is attacked by
bellatrix lestrange
special and practical effects were used
to set the stage for the gruesome attack
on the family home
the special effects team used real fire
to simulate the attack
with a ring of fire spreading around the
set at almost 420 feet long
special effects specialist john
richardson claimed that the ring of fire
was definitely a learning process
as the crew had to learn and re-learn
what ways to make the fire work best on
the set
you're aragorn
the character if you can call it that of
aragog was also a huge component of the
practical effects that made the film
truly stand out the practical effects
team needed to make a completely new
giant spider for this film
says makeup and creature effects
designer nick dudman he's
essentially it's the same character and
he looks essentially the same
although we've upgraded him a little
says dudman
in the creation of this spidery creature
the special effects team chose a
material to produce the spider that was
translucent
to try to mimic what a real dead bug
might look like it took a team of over a
dozen people to work on aragog
including tasks like filling the mold to
airbrushing final details
in fact it took a team of six to seven
people just to work on placing the
spider hairs on the giant creature
which took weeks on end the amount of
effort that went into creating this
giant spider really paid off when paired
with the acting
scene in the film seriously
misunderstood creatures spiders are
the eyes i reckon they unnerve some folk
as nick dudman states
very often even just an inanimate object
like that can have a
you know a little emotive moment which
is nice bringing the cave scene to
magical life was a hugely important step
in the process of making the half-blood
prince
the production team did a lot of
research on caves looking into different
rock formations to use
leading them to the crystal cave idea
they visited a quartz crystal cave in
switzerland
and a salt cave in germany to find
inspiration they also took inspiration
from the cliffs of moher in ireland for
the iconic cave scene
the set itself was too large of a scale
to fully build
so the team took to using cgi to animate
the setting
having gained confidence from their
first all-cg scene in harry potter 5.
you should have let me sir oh no harry
your blood's much more precious than
mine
as the film opens the viewers watch as
death eaters make their way through both
the wizarding world and the muggle world
tearing apart a pedestrian bridge as
they fly through the sky
it's interesting to take an exclusive
look behind the scenes of the making of
this scene
as a lot more went into it than one
might initially expect
what you might not have figured out
about the scene is the insane amount of
effort that went into getting those
soaring shots through the british skies
it took the use of one helicopter and
one stabilized camera to get the perfect
shot
and then obviously quite a bit of cgi
magic to place the death eaters
within the scene
[Music]
the acting in all the harry potter films
worked to set these mainly child
star-studded films apart from the rest
it's no surprise that the acting
performances from stars like emma watson
daniel radcliffe and rupert grint also
shine through in harry potter and the
half-blood prince
but what were their experiences like
behind the scenes and on set
let's dive in can't you trust me let's
start off with the acting involved in
harry and jenny's love story
the blossoming of harry and jenny's
romance takes a central role in the
half-blood prince with the first kiss
shared between the two
counting as a pivotal scene in the film
as the actors behind the kiss dished
it wasn't as smooth and romantic in real
life as it seemed in the film
when everyone comes in and have a look
at the scene you know lighting or the
crew it's a bit embarrassing but i think
after a while
you just gotta accept it daniel
radcliffe revealed that the kiss scene
was a bit awkward for him
since he knew actress bonnie wright who
plays ginny since she was just a child
of about 10 years old
so it's a bit weird doing all that but
it's fine
this scene was the very first one that
bonnie actually shot on set
making the tension almost palpable to
the young actress she stated that i
think the first time is always the worst
but after that it's just like any other
scene that you're filming so it was
actually easier than i realized
harry was also involved in some behind
the scenes goofing with co-star emma
watson
in the magical library scene watson hit
radcliff over the head so hard by
accident
he even said you can really hear the
crunch of paper on bone
you're laughing because you hit me so
hard don't you okay similarly lavender
and ron's kiss scene was also filled
with a bit of tension
and awkwardness it's just such a weird
sort of thing but everyone watching you
and it's just just
didn't feel very this kiss scene was at
a whole new level of weird in comparison
to harry and jenny's because it took
place in front of dozens of extras
daniel radcliffe in particular was
extremely excited about this kiss scene
making a point to be present off camera
while the smooch took place on screen
i don't think rupert had done a kissing
scene and that was entirely new
territory for him
talk about friends cheering each other
on jessie cave who plays lavender
revealed that it was actually the most
awkward to film the rehearsal scene when
it was just her
rupert and the director because that was
much more intimate of a kiss than the
one in front
of the cast was she claimed that the
awkwardness of the kiss was not really a
big deal to her but her true fear when
kissing rupert i was more concerned
anyway about honestly chipping a tooth
i really was worried another interesting
yet much more serious note about the
acting during the half-blood prince was
maggie smith's health during filming
the actress who famously plays professor
mcgonagall in the series was actually
undergoing breast cancer treatment
during the time of filming
she was working on set while undergoing
chemotherapy at the same
time which was no small feat as the
actress said she was in pain constantly
and also feeling
deathly sick smith tried to make light
of the situation and is even quoted
saying
i was hairless i had no problem getting
the wig on i was like a boiled egg
it's clear that the special effects and
the actors both work to make this film
truly special
but what about the rest of the
production team that also made the magic
of the half blood prince come to life
it's clear that the production decisions
from the screenwriters to the director
worked to make this chapter of the harry
potter series truly special
the director of harry potter and the
half-blood prince david yates truly
shared a unique bond with the actors on
set
making their relationship as well as his
professional choices
inherently important to the production
of hp6 not just for me as a storyteller
but also
with the actors i wanted to see them
play more comedy
some of his decisions were a bit
controversial despite his general
popularity
among the actors on set it's been
revealed that screenwriter steve cloves
actually argued back and forth with
yates over whether or not they should
include more pencil memory scenes
showing voldemort's background in the
movie yates ended up actually vetoing
the writer's wishes
opting for less of the voldemort
flashbacks to be included in the film
who are you when i'm like you tom
i'm different prove it
film editor mark day was also a big
player in the creation of the half-blood
prince and his decisions also influenced
the way the film came out for sure
with a total of five editors for the
harry potter series in total
mark day has stuck around to edit two of
them in total
day worked for 14 months editing the
film making decisions when to cut to
different shots within a scene and being
responsible for more than 1
700 edits within the film editing is
very subjective and so what you may
think is a good cut
i may not not only do the director and
editors have big roles in the production
process
but so do lesser acknowledge team
members like stunt specialists
they're in charge of all the quidditch
acrobatics that the actors have to
perform
including some of these impressive and
not so impressive saves made by the
keeper ron weasley behind the scenes
and we can't forget the important makeup
artists like amanda knight who make
all the magic of the story really come
to life before our eyes
as we can see here amanda transforms
actress emma watson by giving her the
dark mark with a temporary tattoo
after all of this in-depth info on the
making of the film
it's clear that a lot went into harry
potter and the half-blood prince
from casting and acting choices to
special effects
the various components that went into
the film surely paid off with the end
product
how did finding out about all these
behind the scenes details
change how you see the film let us know
in the comments